can 150 headphones you really compete
with those that cost three four or even
550 dollars well after closer to two
weeks now i have to say yes now when
soundcore by anchor reached out to me
and wanted me to check out these
unreleased headphones and sponsor a
video i was a little skeptical because i
always thought you have to spend a ton
of money if you want high quality but
after i looked at the reviews on their
previous headphones i was very surprised
and intrigued and wanted to check them
out these are the new space q45s from
soundcore by anchor and they have some
very impressive specs and upgrades
compared to the previous ones now the
first thing that i want to talk about is
what budget headphones have a tough time
with and that is active noise
cancellation these things have four
microphones they have an algorithm that
automatically adjust for your
environment and when i first put them on
i was very surprised by how well it
worked right now i'm here in the office
we have a vent with ac noise and it's
blocking out all of that noise just like
my airpods max do which i've been using
ever since they came out probably a year
and a half or so
now the ultimate test isn't an airplane
which i haven't flown in the last two
weeks but it is my lawnmower that thing
is insanely loud way louder than an
airplane and i was shocked when i put
these on and i was mowing it got rid of
almost all of the sound it got rid of
all the low end and left a little bit of
highs
in fact it got rid of more low end than
the airpods max did
the high end was a little bit higher but
overall i was just very very impressed
that headphones that cost 150 bucks can
do that now a part of it might be this
seal it is a memory foam seal and it is
super soft and it does seal well without
putting as much pressure on my head and
ears as my earpods do and after using
them in various situations like in my
office listening to music and blocking
out all the sound also when i was in the
car my wife is driving my kids are being
loud i would say that these perform
better than the bose that i have tested
and shown off on this channel and i was
not expecting that now you can also
adjust the active noise cancellation in
the app which also has a lot of features
that i will be going over in a little
bit but the next thing i want to talk
about is the battery life i literally
have charged these one time in all this
use that's because they are rated for 50
hours of battery life which is insane
now my air pods they're rated for about
20 but they actually get lower than that
because i don't use this case with them
so a lot of times they're still on
before they power down and other
competitors like the sony xm5s they're
rated for 30 with active noise
cancellation so 50 with the active noise
cancellation is incredible but if you
shut that off they get 65
hours of battery life now i don't know
if it's because they have a large
battery in here i don't know if it's
because of the bluetooth 5.3 which also
does help but that is very impressive
and they can also fast charge where in
just five minutes you get four hours of
playback now they do include a case and
unlike this one it is actually a very
nice case it's hard with a zipper and a
loop and then inside you can pull out
this little insert if you don't want it
there they also give you a three
millimeter headphone cord uh which is
also nicely dumped to buy that
separately and then you get a usb c
charging cable as far as the build
quality it is also better than i
expected these hinges are aluminum and
then the top here is metal it's not
plastic and the components that are
plastic don't feel cheap we have this
hinge that adjusts and it just clicks
so you can fine tune that and what i
really love is that these fold in so
they're nice and compact if you want to
just toss them in your bag without a
case of course the airpods don't do that
and the new xm5s also don't do that so
that is very nice as far as controls we
have physical buttons on both ear cups
so on one side we have a power button
next to the charging cable and led we
have the active noise cancellation
button so you can toggle that and then
on the other side we have our volume
buttons and then a plate and pause as
well as the headphone jack and yes the
headphone jack can be used even if
they're dead it will accept power you
don't have to have them pre-charged like
my earpods as far as comforts the
longest that i've used them is probably
four to five hours and i didn't have any
issues i do feel the band a little bit
more so than my ear pods but that's the
same case for the bose for the sony's
but on the plus side my ears fit great
and there is very little pressure around
them even though we have a nice tight
fit for the active noise cancellation
now one downside compared to air pods is
that it doesn't connect to all your
icloud devices and switch automatically
which that's because of apple they lock
all that down so it's the same thing for
any other headphone brand but on the
plus side these have multi points so
they can connect to multiple devices at
the same time
so if you're on your laptop and you're
working and they're also connected to
your phone you can just use that and
it'll switch over or if you get a phone
call then i'll switch over automatically
you can pair them with more devices than
that but then the previous one last one
that was connected it will just
disconnect and connect to whatever else
you want as far as microphone quality it
is above average as well we have those
multiple mics there with noise reduction
so my wife didn't have any issues when i
was talking to her and that also brings
us into the transparency mode because it
uses those mics and it also works better
than i expected typically for budget
headphones this is where it really falls
flat uh the different brands where they
just can't do a good job with that
processing and anker has done a really
good job
you could tell that it is going through
the microphones but you don't get any of
that weird kind of staticky uh or very
high pitch kind of sound that i've heard
from other headphones that cost a lot
more the transparency mode is also
customizable
so you can go ahead and fine-tune that
to your liking and now let's get into
what matters a lot and that is sound
quality now out of the box for me
personally it was a little bit of a
downside not because it sounds bad it
doesn't these things have dual 40
millimeter double layer diaphragm
drivers that also support high-res audio
but i personally like a little bit more
bass and the highs to be a little bit
sharper now i did go into the app and
you can actually switch from their
signature stock sound to other modes
that they have preset and those modes
actually make a good difference
depending on what you want sometimes
there's very little difference between
them but i actually went into the custom
mode and i fine-tuned it for my liking
not only was i able to get it to play
louder uh but also add a little bit of
that low end and a little bit on the
high end so this is my personal settings
if you guys pick them up you guys can go
ahead and try that out or create your
own out of the box the sound is very
natural still has some bass and stuff uh
and if you're somebody that's coming
from bose it actually might be perfect
for you with those settings now in the
app you can customize your noise
cancellation or your transparency you
can go into the safe volume mode which
will actually read the volume of your
music and tell you if it is safe for
your ears you can also hit that limit
volume button if you want to protect
your hearing you can also go into
controls and then you can customize what
happens when you are pressing
your buttons here for the power button
and to switch through the modes if you
don't want one of these and there's also
an option to double click to do base up
if you want to get a quick boost of bass
they also have this talk mode where the
music volume is automatically adjusted
by them and it is lowered if you're
going to be talking uh if you're using
that transparency mode which is pretty
cool so overall these things impressed
me way more than i expected i thought
for 150 bucks you're gonna get something
that's decent the sound quality is going
to be a lot worse
the transparency mode is going to be
terrible the active noise cancellation
is going to be you know somewhat there
but nothing like the higher end
headphones
but sound core by anchor has delivered
their previous headphones have great
reviews which is why i said yes to
checking these out and doing this video
and then these ones take it to another
level giving you i mean i would say at
least 300
350 400 worth of value for 150 bucks so
if you guys want a pair of great
headphones that's not going to break the
bank make sure you guys go and check out
the link in the video description you
guys can check them out and see what you
think now if you already bought these
space q45s or a different set by
soundcore comment down below let me know
your thoughts on them and what your
experience is and i think at this point
i'm gonna keep my eyes out way more for
anchor headphones because you just get
such a great value
so thank you guys for watching make sure
you guys check out the link in the video
description if you guys want to get more
info about these or pick up a pair click
that circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]